oh my god
oh
that is an unbelievable goal yeah it
just reminds me of the one i scored
against manchester it's very similar
yeah you're a glory this one well i'll
be honest with you mine was against joe
hart
[Laughter]
hi i'm peter crouch watch my show peter
crouch save our beautiful game on
discovery plus this
is rate my skills support bible
oh little drag back
oh
[Applause]
to me is what
suddenly football should be about
it's got it's got absolutely everything
in there he looks like a
like george best
unbelievable skills little nutmeg
unbelievable the
skill key skills in a 50-50 munch on the
edge of the box
you must have been like so sick of
hearing the words good feet for a big
man the thing is with me i always had i
always had good technique and i was i
was always tall so i had to work on my
heading and being a target man if you
like but i always had i always felt i
had the ability just i was
different
we're in someone's back garden here
that is spectacular he started it
fantastically well got the elevation
little flick i think he was so proud of
the back hill
he just continued to walk straight over
the goal and over the garden fence
fantastic
oh nice
oh my god
oh
that is an unbelievable goal
well it's just it's a bad clearance he's
popped it up i have to say it just
reminds me of the one i scored against
man city it's very similar yeah you're a
glory this one well i'll be honest with
you mine was against joe hart
[Laughter]
but still an unbelievable strike i'm
sure it would have beaten joe hart as
well
right nice pitch
3g
oh
unbelievable finish
most of my overhead kicks were someone
crossing from the byline backwards you
get elevated so
with the cross coming from deep
i'll have to say is a more difficult
skill
the technique is
fantastic
almost a no-look finish as well
i used to love
like the overhead kicks i used to
practice them as a kid all the time
[Laughter]
so i've been there many a time you know
in the garden um
yeah i remember smashing the
the uh of our back patio door um with a
low stinging drive
and uh yeah i wasn't too pleased with
that but yeah i mean he's obviously he
knows he's hit it over
and um the words have come out of his
mouth
[Laughter]
oh my god
wow the reaction from the crowd
i think
half the
staff are on the pitch um yeah i mean
this is this is this is unbelievable
outside the box robonaut into the top
corner the keepers got under it
how hard is it to do everyone from that
distance
it's so hard to generate the power it's
great technique
yeah so number three i'm going for good
feet for a big man there he is got the
seven on his back lovely drag back
another one
silky skills is for me it's just it's
just perfect sunday league football
you've got the the ability down the
right some good players sunderly you've
got on the side silky skills and then
he gives the ball away and smashes him
perfect
right in second place i'm going i'm
going to go with the uh the recreation
of my goal stoke versus man city keeping
the ball up and volleying into the into
the side netting past the hapless young
joe heart
right in first place i'm gonna have to
go with the scissor kick the overall
kick
i'm coming from deep
to be able to twist in the air and get
get the angle on the pool unbelievable
finish and uh that's my number one
oh he's good
why is he in sky blue though should be
in red that's the problem that's the
biggest problem with this kid he's
wearing their own colour oh he's not
scored that that is unbelievable
wow was that cross as well do you think
i do think he's meant to chip it into
the back post they don't really matter
does it the bit before it was fantastic